Vielen Dank dass DU bei clixoom,
der Online-Talkshow vorbeischaust.
Wie ist die Lage?
Ich habe ein wirklich gutes Gefühl.
Ich suche immer noch nach Freiheit.
(Anm.- Alles Anspielungen auf Songtitel)
Ich bin verrückt nach Dir, und
ich tanze jeden Morgen den Limbo.
(Anm.- Alles Anspielungen auf Songtitel)
- Okay.
- Alles läuft großartig.
Ja? Sie sind ein Spitzenschauspieler, Sie haben
Dr. Jeckyll und Mr. Hyde am Broadway gespielt - großartig.
Aber Sie machen so etwas wie...
es ist Partymucke! Warum haben Sie
sich entschieden solche Musik zu machen?
Ich habe mich für diese Musikrichtung
entschieden, weil das Musiklabel meinte
"Du solltest... Du kannst nicht..."
Ich habe ein Album das The Romantics heißt, welches
weitestgehend so ist wie der Song This Time Around
der meine Geschichte erzählt,
und ich habe einen Song mit meinen Kindern,
und The Romantics wurde von Frank Wildhorn
geschrieben, der auch die ganze Musik für
Jeckyll und Hyde gemacht hat.
Es ist schon irgendwie riesig, ziemlich
klassisches Broadway halt. Und die Produzenten
sagten "Oh nein, wir sind hier in Deutschland"
Du musst Looking For Freedom bringen. Du  musst
Schlager singen. Komm schon, man ♪ Crazy For You ♪.
"Schlager, Schlager, Schlager".
Und ich sagte - okay.
"Aber einen Song will ich wirklich unbedingt
machen, und das ist It's A Real Good Feeling".
Und sie meinten... weil mein... Ich fühlte mich dannach,
also haben wir eine Rockversion davon aufgenommen
und wir haben das Album aufgenommen,
weil wir dachten- "Ich weiss nicht
ob noch irgendwer Alben kauft".
Vielleicht lädt jemand Good Feeling herunter,
vielleicht drei oder vier weitere Lieder.
Aber die meinten "Nein, es gibt immer noch
Leute die CDs kaufen", also haben wir ein Paar
schöne Balladen und Schlager aufgenommen.
Und dann meinte ich "Lasst es uns testen".
Und wir gingen auf Tournee um die Musik zu testen,
um zu sehen wie es ankommt.
Und es war ziemlich erfolgreich.
Also ich weiß nicht ob wir Scheiben
verkaufen werden, aber es ist eine Möglichkeit um
irgendwie wieder auf dem deutschen Markt
Fuss zu fassen, damit ich auf Tournee gehen kann.
Und bisher sieht's ziemlich gut aus.
Also ist für Sie die Musikqualität zweitrangig,
und es ist wichtiger Erfolg damit zu haben?
Es ist wichtiger Spaß zu haben.
- Spaß zu haben, nat...
- Ja, und wenn man mein Konzert besucht,
wenn man in meinem Konzert gewesen ist,
bekommt man zweieinhalb Stunden verrückten Spaß.
- Und ich meine verrückten Spaß.
- Yeah.
Da sind Typen die sich als mich verkleiden.
Da sind Leute die zu viel trinken,
und dann sind da noch Leute die sagen
"Oh David Hasselhoff" und kleine Kinder und Omas
die ♪ I've been looking for freedom ♪ singen,
und natürlich auch die Balladen...
Es ist ein gigantischer
Querschnitt durch die Bevölkerung.
Es ist ein ungewöhnliches Album,
weil von allem für jeden etwas dabei ist.
Also ich weiß nicht ob mein Publikum die
Platten auch kauft. Ich weiß es wirklich nicht.
Ich habe keinen Schimmer ob sich das verkauft
oder nicht. Und manchmal träume ich nachts
Oh mein Gott, wir sind auf Platz 46 in den Charts.
Und dann wache ich auf und frag mich
"Was stimmt nicht mit mir?"
Alles was ich die Leute wissen
lassen will, ist dass Rock 'n' Roll und
Musikantenstadl für mich eins sind.
Es ist Unterhaltung.
Wenn Du mich zum Musikantenstadl bringst
dann habe ich die Verpflichtung
dazu diese Menschen zu unterhalten. Die
fangen nicht an mit "Hey, wir wollen abrocken".
Und wenn ich in einem Club bin
mache ich die Rocknummer und den House-Mix
und ich lasse es richtig krachen, weißt Du?
Und wenn ich irgendwo anders bin wo
Kinder sind, dann will ich was für die Kinder machen.
Okay, Du sagtest verrückt... Gestern Abend habe
ich einen amerikanischen Produzenten getroffen.
Der hat mal ein Interview mit Dir gemacht und
meinte, ähm, David Hasselhoff der ist verrückt.
Stimmt das?
Bist Du ein bisschen verrückt?
Der letzte der zu mir sagte
ich sei verrückt war Russell Brand.
- Okay.
- Russell Brand interviewte mich
und meinte dann "Du bist verrückt".
Und ich meinte "Du nennst mich verrückt?
Weißt Du, ich bin ziemlich normal"
Ich bin nur auf eine lustige Art verrückt.
Ich bin kein verrückter Mann.
Ich bin Vater. Ich liebe es auf der Bühne
zu stehen und dort verückte Dinge zu machen.
Den meisten Spaß habe ich wirklich beim Auftritt
Und der Rest des Reisens und... Es ist wie hier in Hamburg.
Ich meine ich war noch gar nicht draußen, weißt Du?
Ich will in's Atlantic Hotel
rübergehen und Udo Hallo sagen.
- Haha, den kennst Du?
- Ja klar!
Jeden, Matthias Reim, Udo Lindenberg, Udo Jürgens.
Ich war immer mal hier, seit 1989.
Dieter Bohlen. Ich kenne sie ALLE.
Hör mal, Howard Carpendale, Oh mein Gott.
Ich kenne sogar die Flippers, die immer
noch leben, und immer noch dabei sind.
- Okay, bist Du ein Fan deutscher Musik?
- Ich sehe die in jeder Show, man.
Ja, und die kommen alle an... -Hallo! -Hallo!
Und das ist toll, weil ich Leute mit langem Atem mag.
Weil das sind die echten, wahren Stars für mich.
Udo Lindenberg, Udo Jürgens, Howard Carpendale,
Scheißegal ob man ihre Musik mag
oder nicht, sogar Andreas Rau(?).
Es gibt sie immer noch, Baby. Und wenn man
in diesem Geschäft 20 Jahre überdauern kann,
- ist das verdammt nochmal unglaublich.
- Okay, ja das stimmt.
Also was ist das Geheimnis, im Besonderen
das Geheimnis Deines Erfolges in Deutschland?
Ähm, einfach immer Wiederkehren, wie Weihnachten.
Ich komme jedes Jahr zurück.
Weihnachten kommt - also auch The Hoff.
Das Geheimnis ist eine tolle Zeit zu haben.
Das Geheimnis ist hundert Prozent zu geben.
Weißt Du was alle zu mir sagen? "Dein Konzert
war abgefahren, und Du bist in Spitzenform."
Hör mal, ich bekomme diese Kraft von den Menschen.
Also Frage ich "Wollt Ihr feiern?"
Weißt Du, jeden Abend komme ich von der Bühne
und denke "Ich kann das nicht mehr, ich bin 58".
Aber ich kann jeden überdauern,
weil ich wirklich dieses Gefühl genieße.
Ich meine ich kann das, weil egal ob
da zweitausend oder zehntausend Menschen sind,
irgendwie kann ich auf eine Person zoomen. Und wenn
ich auf eine Person zoomen und auf sie wirken kann
und sie gucken- und ich gucke zu ihnen- und
erwische sie, kann ich sie wirklich mitreißen.
Und das ist mir auch schon passiert.
Wenn jemand mich fokussiert, wenn ich
in's Theater gehe, dann mach ich
"Whoa" und fühle dieses tolle Gefühl.
Und so beeinflusst Unterhaltung Menschen auf
eine emotionale Weise, ob es sie zum Weinen bringt
sie nachdenklich macht, sie glücklich macht,
sie realisieren läßt dass sie dankbar
sein sollten für das was wir haben.
Auch wenn man den Fernseher einschaltet
und sieht was auf der Welt geschieht,
und Reality-TV sieht, welches Müll ist und
Menschen dazu bringt bescheuerte Dinge zu tun.
Menschen haben ein gutes Herz
und sie wollen glücklich sein,
und sie wollen lebensbejahend sein.
Und wir alle vergessen das manchmal,
aber kommt auf mein Konzert,
das wird mal etwas anderes sein
und das ist irgendwie-
Ich sauge diese Energie von Leuten auf
also wenn ich denke ich fange an
das Leben zu ernst zu nehmen und "Oh wow" werde
denke ich daran einfach vor die Tür
zu gehen und jemanden Anzusprechen,
und die Kumpels "Hallo-, Hallo,- Hallo"
und ich denke "Wow, wie cool ist das?"
- Okay, also ich wünsche Dir ein wirklich gutes Gefühl.
- Danke vielmals!
I'm crazy for you.
(Ich bin verrückt nach Dir.)